en la unidad de cáncer del hospital
augusta victoria el doctor giuseppe
saluda a más personal cap a 100 test
está vacío
aquí deberían tratarse a diario unos 80
palestinos pero el vacío no se debe a
una remisión de la enfermedad sino a una
crisis de fondos desde septiembre de
2021 el centro se ha visto obligado a
rechazar a 500 nuevos pacientes ya
posponer la atención de más de 600
interrumpir protocolos para mí es una
catástrofe
alrededor del 40% de nuestros pacientes
no pueden venir a los hospitales recibir
sus tratamientos a tiempo debido a la
falta de medicamentos
hasta ahora el hospital había sorteado
la deuda de más de 70 millones de
dólares de la autoridad palestina
también la pandemia y la inexistencia de
eeuu bajo donald trump pero no contaba
con que la unión europea bloqueará su
contribución anual por el rechazo de
algunos miembros al contenido de los
libros de texto palestinos
las consecuencias las sufren pacientes
como esta mujer de 39 años con cáncer de
mama y destinada al quirófano si no
llega al fármaco por el que espera hace
casi dos meses
confía en nosotros
por supuesto que confío pero necesito mi
tratamiento y por favor les pido que
intenten no hacer lo mismo con otras
mujeres
[Música]
este hospital luterano es la única
acción para los enfermos de cáncer de
gaza' y el mejor para los de cisjordania
ocupada
soy de ebro la distancia del hospital de
ramala es grande además proveen otros
hospitales pero no encontré la atención
que hay aquí perderíamos mucho si este
centro desapareciera
a la búsqueda de dinero está volcado el
doctor fadi no solo para sostener los
tratamientos que peligran sino socorrer
a quienes quedaron al margen y esto es
muy frustrante no sólo para mí sino para
todos mis doctores
a veces caemos en depresión
estamos intentando llevar nuestra voz a
la comisión europea para decirles que
bloquear este dinero está hiriendo a
nuestro hospital a nuestros pacientes se
trata de vidas humanas no de política
más allá de algunas ayudas de la onu y
alemania fadi deja claro que si no se
liberan los fondos europeos a fines de
junio la unidad de cáncer podría dejar
de funcionar